pour pâqu Fabrice gilotte fait son
cirque et pas de souci c'est lui-même
qu' le dit comme chaque année le maître
chocolatier nous propose une thématique
tout droit sortie de son imagination un
plaisir pour les yeux et les papilles
bien loin de la traditionnelle cocotte
en
chocolat il viennent avant tout chercher
du bonheur et du plaisir parce que le
chocolat c'est du bonheur et du plaisir
mais je pense qu'ils viennent surtout
chez nous parce qu' des produits qu'on
que l'on ne retrouve nulle part ailleurs
et comme l'homme ne tient pas en place
PAC est déjà loin derrière lui d'autres
projets ont déjà germé dans sa tête plus
marketing cette fois-ci car la maison
gilotte est avant tout une entreprise
familiale qui investit après quatre
boutiques au Japon le père et le fils
s'attaquent au marché français et cible
les villes de province le principe c'est
un développement maîtrisé et sélectif
c'estàd que nous ne souhaitons pas
ouvrir 50 boutiques Fabri gilotte à
travers la France mais plutôt une
boutique par an dans des villes
sélectionnées avec des partenaires de
qualité qui seront indépendants et qui
géreront leur propre boutique ça vous ça
vous pose pas problème de prêter votre
gilotte aux autres pas du tout ah moi
les les meilleures choses pe être
diffusé partager à mon avis hein non non
c'est très
bien à terme la maison pourrait doubler
de taille passant d'une production de 50
tonnes de chocolat par an à une centaine
mais surtout rassurez-vous chez gilotte
ce ne sera jamais la marmotte qui mettra
le chocolat dans le papier
d'alu